[Music]
on this tuesday night the fate of people
hiding in a bombed out steel plant
who was able to emerge after two months
underground it was risk where are they
now and what about the others still
trapped plus some ukrainians returning
home to nothing
diverting disaster just too much water
too fast the race to save homes in
southern manitoba stifling conditions
the extreme weather smothering india and
pakistan and after being penalized by
the pandemic this is the first time back
to normal the much needed shot for bars
pubs and restaurants
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what's happening at that
steel plant in mariupol ukraine where
hundreds of people have been sheltering
it's believed about 100 people including
women and children got out on sunday
with the help of the international red
cross and the u.n but they have yet to
arrive at an agreed to reception center
in ukraine and russian shelling of the
steel plant began again just moments
after the buses left the fate of
hundreds of other people still sheltered
under the plant hang in the balance our
coverage tonight begins with redmond
shannon
freedom from azerstal this video was
provided by a ukrainian politician it
appears to show some of the people who
clambered out from beneath mariupol's
surrounded steel plant over the weekend
we were trapped for two months says this
woman ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky says so far around 100
civilians have been brought out in an
operation supported by the united
nations and the red cross
at a village just outside mariupol some
of the exhausted evacuees described the
conditions they lived in since the start
of the invasion she knew music for the
boston where you look
for a month 40 of us were sharing just
six tins of food a day says this woman
we boiled to that food in buckets
she says she first thought they'd only
need to shelter below the steel works
for two or three days not two months
an aide to the mayor of marupaul says
russia resumed shelling the compound on
sunday after the first evacuation
the planned destination for the civilian
convoy is zaparisia on monday some
civilians made it there from other parts
of maryupol by any means possible
it was a risk but they
wanted to
to get from marupo so
we decided that it is worth it this
woman says her uncle in ukraine's armed
forces is likely still inside azov style
the deputy commander of azov brigade a
group that first formed as
ultra-nationalist ukrainians opposing
russian forces says around 20 children
and hundreds of adult civilians are
still inside he says some are buried
beneath rubble and many of his soldiers
are injured or dead this evocation
effort covers only civilians
and we still have
ukrainian defenders who including
wounded
severely wounded
ukrainian soldiers possibly as many as
two thousand of them if and when the
last civilians get out it seems doubtful
russia will show much mercy for the
remaining soldiers according to the
kremlin some of them are from canada
redmond shannon global news london
russia has not stopped its attacks but
there is a new assessment of how
weakened its forces are the latest uk
ministry of defense intelligence report
says it believes russia committed over
120 battalion tactical groups to the
invasion which is about 65 percent of
its ground combat strength the uk
believes it's likely more than a quarter
of those units have now been rendered
combat ineffective some of russia's
elite units have suffered the most
including airborne forces the uk
believes it could take years for russia
to reconstitute those forces
there's widespread condemnation of what
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
said about nazi leader adolf hitler
having jewish origins
israeli foreign minister yaer lapid
called it an unforgivable scandalous
statement and a terrible historical
mistake lavrov was asked on italian tv
why russia claims it is de-nazifying
ukraine when president vladimir zelinski
is himself jewish lavrov said hitler
also had jewish blood germany's
government calls that absurd propaganda
the stabbing for foreign minister levrov
is false
is despicable and is deemed of the
strongest condemnation
he's basically engaging in holocaust
inversion making the victims of the
holocaust the perpetrators and
that is inexcusable
and in his nightly address today
ukrainian president zelinski said russia
has forgotten all the lessons of world
war ii or perhaps
never learned them
millions of ukrainians have fled their
homes because of russia's invasion
others have stayed to fight or have no
safe way out and in places now liberated
from russian control people are trying
to find a way to live again crystal
commansing met people in a village near
cherniv where nearly every home has been
destroyed or damaged
even weeks after the fighting the air
these survivors breathe is still tainted
with smoke
homeless traumatized yet still
open-hearted to strangers
spent 21 days in the basement
i saw a woman belong to pieces she was
in her kitchen cooking food while they
targeted her house yeah
i want to say that it was not easy to
survive
across ukraine many elderly immobile and
sick were forced to shelter in place
when the full invasion began on february
24th
this northeast village is less than 100
kilometers from the russian and
belarusian borders
here people endured aerial and ground
assaults for roughly five weeks by
invading forces
[Music]
cries while explaining how in her
lifetime she's lost two homes
first in the chernobyl disaster
and now in this war
it was so hard to look at your open
house burning where i lived for 40 years
nearly every home here is in ruins
villagers say during the second world
war nazis leveled their community now
russians did the same
the russians are even worse than the
nazis this village nova selivka was
liberated by ukrainian forces about a
month ago the damage is catastrophic and
people in this small village are going
without they are waiting for
humanitarian aid
including temporary shelters
occasional donations of food are
provided by soldiers or hare krishnas
the group says they found places to
sleep but don't expend on where or with
whom
they come back daily to tend to their
modest gardens but they also come back
because this is their home
we're just waiting i don't know where we
can live if no one will help us we won't
be able to rebuild our houses
the war has caused the biggest
humanitarian crisis in europe in decades
a crisis these ukrainians
never imagined would leave them with
nothing
crystal commansing global news nova
scotia ukraine
members of the european union could not
agree today on exactly how to reduce
their dependence on russian energy eu
energy ministers held an emergency
meeting to come up with a united
response to moscow's demand that foreign
buyers pay for russian gas in rubles or
be cut off russia has already cut off
supplies to bulgaria and poland after
they refused to comply with its payment
scheme the european energy commissioner
says that strengthened the eu's will to
stop using russian fossil fuels
and it is an unjustified breach of
existing contracts and a warning that
any member state could be next
audrey simpson says the risk of energy
shortages in europe is low because there
are alternative supplies but putting
them in place will take time according
to the center for research on energy in
clear air europe eu countries have paid
more than 45 billion euros to russia for
gas and oil since it invaded ukraine on
february 24th
it's good to have you here
thank you for coming
nancy pelosi was in poland today the
speaker of the u.s house of
representatives met lawmakers and the
polish president she and the delegation
thanked the polish people for opening
their hearts and homes to ukrainians
poland has taken in more than three
million refugees since the war began
pelosi was in keeve on the weekend
meeting ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky
now to this country in southern manitoba
another weekend of heavy rain has forced
evacuations in some areas because of
flooding parts of the province have
received four to six times the normal
amount of precipitation this spring
hardest hit right now is the pegus first
nation 180 kilometers north of winnipeg
more than one thousand people are under
a mandatory evacuation order after ice
jams on the fisher river drove up water
levels roads are awash and some 480
homes are surrounded by water residents
were sent to hotels and nearby
communities including selkirk gimli and
winnipeg
other parts of the province including
flood-prone areas near winnipeg have
been preparing for what people feared
was coming brittany greenslade is near
carmen manitoba tonight
donna residents all along this rural
road were forced out of their homes this
weekend as rising flood waters came fast
this ditch is now filled with more than
a meter of water cutting off access to
some homes just too much water too fast
it just absolutely could not
they just couldn't cope with it
with such speed and volume these homes
in the regional municipality of dufferin
about 85 kilometers southwest of
winnipeg didn't stand a chance each
protected by dikes that couldn't keep
the flood waters out there's been some
concerns over the years but they've
never been compromised like this now
they've got a swimming pool right in
front of their yard
just down the street this home is
surrounded the family is doing its best
to sandbag 200 volunteers were out
sandbagging in the surrounding areas
this weekend i know we picked up 20 000
sandbags yesterday from winnipeg just to
assist with the efforts manitobans are
no stranger to overland flooding but may
have avoided a worst case scenario this
time
water in the diversion rose nearly a
foot sunday according to the mayor but
it appears the situation is stabilizing
the waters have gone down six inches
overnight and our diversion here is
doing its job like it's supposed to and
it's saved carmen numerous times over
the last 31 years
a bit further south in morton which also
remains under a local state of emergency
the focus is now on cleanup i found
myself very lucky because the water
didn't get into the garage
and it didn't get into my basement it
was kind of scary i have to tell you
that i was a little a little stressed
through the whole thing across southern
manitoba those floodwaters are slowly
receding in many communities but until
all of that water is gone it's hard to
get a true picture of just how much
damage has been done
brittany greenslade global news near
carman
manitoba canada's electric vehicle
industry has been given a boost thanks
to an injection of public money zelantis
announced it will spend 3.6 billion
dollars to retool its plants in windsor
and brampton ontario to produce electric
vehicles prime minister justin trudeau
said the project will help make canada a
global leader in electric vehicles
it'll deliver for workers it'll deliver
for communities it'll deliver for our
economy
and it'll deliver for the environment
the federal and ontario governments are
each providing more than 500 million
dollars to support the project
the sex assault trial for canadian
musician and headley frontman jacob
hogard got underway in a toronto
courtroom today after it was delayed
multiple times because of the pandemic
the trial before a jury was requested by
hogard the 34 year old pleaded not
guilty during a preliminary hearing in
2019 after he was charged in 2018 with
one count of sexual interference and two
counts of sexual assault causing bodily
harm police allege the charges relate to
three separate incidents with a woman
and a teenager in 2016. the trial is
expected to run until early june seeing
orange coming up the eerie phenomenon
enveloping iraq's capital plus heatwave
the scorching hot weather suffocating
india and pakistan
a record-breaking heat wave has swept
over india and pakistan putting the
lives of millions of people at risk the
month of april was india's hottest in
122 years maximum temperatures averaging
more than 37 degrees last month delhi
recorded seven consecutive days over 40
degrees and on friday southeastern
pakistan suffered a scorching 47 degrees
climate scientists say what's worrying
is not just how hot it is but the extent
and the duration of the heat wave
eerie orange skies have again engulfed
iraq blanketing the capital baghdad
another choking dust storm settled over
the capitol streets on sunday and again
today seeping into homes and grounding
flights dozens of people have been taken
to the hospital with respiratory issues
experts warn the phenomenon is becoming
more frequent because of drought and
declining rainfall
ahead the first report from nova
scotia's mass casualty commission why it
brings little comfort to families
the inquiry into the mass shooting in
nova scotia in 2020 released its interim
report today after six months of
fact-finding and speaking with witnesses
it lays out how the mass casualty
commission is going about its work and
defends its decision to limit witness
testimony but as ross lord reports it
doesn't advance the public's
understanding of what happened and why
when they reluctantly agreed to a public
inquiry into the port-a-pick massacre
the federal and nova scotia governments
ordered an interim report to keep the
public apprised of their work the mass
casualty commission has now filed its
first formal report which is heavy
unprocessed and short on what the
inquiry has uncovered some of that
information has been shared before but i
think it's useful to bring it all
together again
so that individuals who are engaged with
our work who are watching our work
understand you know where we are in the
process
much of the 84-page report dwells on how
the commission is going about its work
and how it will continue gathering
evidence and hearing from witnesses to
those watching the inquiry closely the
theme of the report is not surprising
but the lawyer who represents the
majority of victims families says she
and her clients are disappointed i don't
think any of us expected there to be any
any sort of factual findings or
conclusions drawn in this interim report
but um that it is
essentially silent on any of that is
discouraging
along with in-person hearings the
commission has released thousands of
pages of documents some detailing the
rcmp's confusion as the gunman was
killing 22 people three separate callers
to 9-1-1 tried to tell the maudies the
killer was dressed as one of them and
was driving a replica rcmp vehicle but
he eluded authorities for 13 hours as
officers struggled with technology and
communication before police killed him
after a chance encounter at a gas
station the interim report does include
a reference to mental health and hard
hit communities saying we encourage
governmental and non-governmental
agencies to provide the necessary mental
health trauma and bereavement supports i
expect it will be an area that we will
see recommendations on a final report
once we have more information and had
more opportunity to examine that a
little further upcoming witnesses
include senior rcmp managers who've been
criticized for not initiating an
emergency alert to the public the mass
casualty commission's final report
including lessons learned and
recommendations is due in november
ross lord global news halifax
pandemic recovery canadian style next
how hockey is helping put bars back in
business
jeopardy fans are holding their breath
canadian mateo roach is going for her
20th win in a row tonight her family
already knows what happens next but
they're keeping their lips sealed
well i don't know how we would be able
to maintain any composure whatsoever we
didn't know the end result but we don't
know a lot of detail about what happens
in the game so it's still extremely
exciting
that is roach's mother patty mckinnon
she describes matea as a private person
and her younger brother says knowing
millions of viewers have watched the 23
year old from nova scotia excel
is remarkable
i think that she is an incredible role
model for young queer people for young
women and just young people in general
who are traditionally left out or not
included in intellectual spaces so i
think that's really incredible that she
can do that
matea is tied for the sixth longest
jeopardy run in history she'll climb to
fifth if she wins tonight no matter what
though she is already the quiz show's
most successful canadian player
if you're not a jeopardy fan there's
still plenty of other excitement to look
forward to round one of the nhl playoffs
kicks off tonight three canadian teams
are in the running for the stanley cup
and that is music to the ears of bars
and restaurants as heather eurix west
reports they are rooting for any team
that gets a long and lucrative run
three two one
oh the stanley cup it's what hockey fans
fantasize about all year long and right
now all that hope looms large i really
hope they win this year because we've
been waiting so many years and i i just
really want them to win this year waited
a long time myself in edmonton i'd lived
through the glory years as a child so
it's i'm more excited right now with
hopefully the cop coming back to
edmonton while only three of canada's
nhl teams made the playoffs this year
the flames the oilers and the leafs all
enter the first round with home ice
advantage and bar owners are ready to
welcome the playoff crowds it's been a
long time yeah this is the first time
back to normal like back to feeling like
a true play-off norm like a normal run
the hospitality industry is still
climbing out of two years of of being
closed being open and close on the
street known in calgary as the red mile
flames and oilers fans are welcome for
now wins for both teams would mean a
battle of alberta in the second round
and a badly needed boom for business
just seeing all the other businesses
including ours being able to
to finally get our legs back underneath
us and rebuild and then this is just a
you know like we couldn't have asked for
a better way to kick start summer of
course a packed house for a week or two
in may won't erase the impacts of two
years of covet restrictions and closures
and there are new challenges for
business owners as well a shortage of
labor rising food costs and expenses
but if a canadian team was able to make
a lengthy run it's huge right you know
the collective memory and collected new
mood is a is a thing right it's just
that much needed energy boost and that
positivity that is as needed right now a
pandemic pallet cleanser like only a
magical playoff push can provide so go
flames go heather yorick's west global
news calgary
that is global national for this monday
i'm donna friesen tonight's your canada
is the morris island conservation area
near arnprior ontario please email your
photos for viewers at globalnational.com
and thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you